[Applaudissements]
je rêve son visage décline son corps et
puis je l'imaginé habitants mon décor
j'aurais tant à lui dire si j'avais su
parler comment lui faire lire au fond de
mes pensées
ma première fois je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie et vous votre première fois
est ce qu'on vous en souvenez
olala je vois des regards bizarre dans
l'assemblée
ne me dit pas quand même que vous pensez
à la première fois
au mais si vous pensiez à celle là
moi je parlais de vos premières vacances
sont vos parents votre première sortie
en boîte de nuit votre première à chaque
maison ou encore quand moi ce soir votre
première prise de parole en public
aujourd'hui je vis plein de première
fois
première fois que je suis seul sur scène
pour parler
première fois que je suis filmé en
direct
et première fois que je sors de ma vie
devant une assemblée autre que mon mari
mes filles ou ma belle-mère et oui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'étaient les seuls
qui avait eu cette chance d'entendre ma
douce et mélodieuse voix
je blague
tout va bien m'a dit arrête de chanter
hélène mais tu chantes comme un pied va
chanter au bout du jardin
j'imagine que certains ont dit je te
dire la même chose ce soir et je vous
comprends bien
[Musique]
alors je me suis toujours tu
pour plaire aux autres et aller dans
leur sens
bon je sais je ne saurai jamais si
l'union ni mariah carey mais je voulais
démarrer c'est est dicté par une chanson
qui m'a toujours inspiré sans que je ne
comprenne à l'époque pourquoi
aujourd'hui j'ai dépassé ma peur grâce à
cette phrase d'oprah winfrey
on devient ce que l'on croit
que veut-elle dire par là est ce que ça
signifie que j'ai le pouvoir de devenir
qui je suis est ce que j'ai le droit de
choisir de ne plus ouvrir de reprendre
les rênes de ma vie
je me suis très souvent posé cette
question et il ya moins d'un an le
déclic
suivi d'une transformation magique est
fulgurante
alors je me fais une joie ce soir de
vous partager mon histoire pour qu'à la
fin mais cette intervention vous
puissiez vous faire une idée avoue des
raisons qui ont fait que cette chanson a
toujours résonné en moi
comme je vous le disais cette phrase de
prat a résonné en moi comme une formule
magique comme cette bonne fait que l'on
trouvera que l'on voit dans les comptes
et qu'un une formule transforme ta vie
je suis sûr vous voyez tous de quoi je
parle
vous avez tous lu dans notre enfance ou
encore maintenant un héros un modèle qui
vous a inspiré ou qui vous inspirent
toujours
moi il y as au prince mais il y avait
quand j'étais petite sophie de la
comtesse de ségur
elle vivait dans une famille bien sous
tous rapports
elle essayait de se conformer à ce que
les adultes attendait d'elle mouchon
d'air à l'essai brin de folie qui lui
faisait faire des tonnes des bêtises
alors pourquoi je vous parle d'elle
enfin j'étais cette petite fille sage
l'enfant modèle qui faisait ce qu'on lui
demandait de faire et qui sait faisait
la plus petite la plus silencieuse la
plus discrète possible
j'ai grandi ainsi entouré d'amour la
petite dernière après deux garçons
tout le monde disait de moi que j'étais
un rayon de soleil
j'avais toujours le sourire et je
portais toujours des vêtements colorés
mais je ne croyais pas en moi je suis
mis c'est ma vie sans pouvoir la
contrôler
pourquoi vous allez vous demandez
peut-être
tout simplement parce que je voulais
prouver à tout mon entourage que j'étais
quelqu'un d'aimable et oui j'avais
besoin constant mais inconscient à
l'époque de toujours vouloir plaire aux
autres
mais pourquoi
parce que j'ai été abandonné à la
naissance
je suis né dans le sud de l'inde je suis
arrivé à l'aise à l'âge de 16 mois en
france
je suis arrivé dans une famille tout à
fait classiques du nord de la france
toute mon enfance mon adolescence et
jusqu'il ya très peu de temps j'ai vécu
avec l'idée que ma vie en inde des pas
partie de moi je dis soucier sans cesse
les deux jalons ces couples écoute
obstacles approve tacle je n'avais pas
le droit de tomber
je devais prouver à tout mon entourage
que j'ai mérité d'exister et de vivre
tous mes choix toutes mes décisions
aller dans ce sens
je me suis créé une vie remplie d'amour
entourée de ma famille de deux grands
frères protecteurs de mon merveilleux
mari de deux adorables petites filles et
d'un cercle amical solide et stable
j'ai fait de longues études et j'ai
travaillé pendant plus de 10 ans dans la
protection de l'enfance
mais il me manquait toujours quelque
chose
je ne me sentais jamais vraiment moi
même enfin avec qui j'étais pourtant
j'avais tout pour être heureuse
tout
mais il me manquait une chose
faire la paix avec ses passes et en
acceptant cette petite fille
ce petit bébé c'est moi en inde
c'est une photo que mes parents ont reçu
avant que je n'arrive en france
je ne sais pas ce que cette petite fille
vous inspire mais moi je la trouve belle
mais tellement triste
la première étape vous me sentir enfin
moi même était celle-là
accepter que cette petite fille fasse
partie de moi
la prendre par la main et la console et
je dois apprendre à l'aimer à
l'apprivoiser et même à l'adopter
ce bébé c'était moi pas une autre
j'ai commencé alors à reconnaître
qu'elle avait vécu un drame qu aucun
bébé
enfant ou humain ne devrait vivre
pour vous raconter mon histoire en inde
en quelques mots
ma mère est décédée en me donnant la vie
ainsi que mes deux petites soeurs nous
étions des tripettes
dès la naissance
mon monde s'est écroulé en quelques
secondes j'avais perdu les troubles les
personnes --trois les trois personnes
les plus importantes de ma vie et qui
était mon tout
ma bulle avait explosé
j'étais seul
s'embrassent écuries dans sens l'odeur
de ma mère sans sa tendresse et soit la
chaleur de mes soeurs
désormais ce petit bébé ma première
héroïne et je suis si fière d'elle elle
est ma force et fait entièrement partie
de moi
je me suis enfin réconcilié avec cette
petite fille est donc avec moi même
la deuxième étape résider dans
l'acceptation de ma vulnérabilité
j'ai dû lutter pour vivre pour arriver
en france je vous racontais mon arrivée
qui est épique vraiment à trois reprises
mes parents ont été appelés pour des cas
de décaler mon arrivée en belgique
alors bonjour votre petite fille ne va
pas arriver maintenant on a un problème
la première religieuse vient de mourir
alors
je pense que vous allez devoir trouver
une solution peut être par vous même
parce que la deuxième vient mourir
alors
n'attendez pas vraiment parce que là on
n'a toujours pas trouvé de solution la
troisième vient de mourir
je vois tous blêmir mais ne vous
inquiétez pas je ne porte pas malheur
bon c'est vrai puis tous les morts qu'il
y autour de moi on pourrait vite le
croire mais ouf rassurez-vous la 4e
n'est pas morte
et grâce à son incroyable instinct de
survie parce que je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi on peut vraiment
parler à ce stade la ddt c'est en survie
me voilà enfin arrivé en belgique sous
des flots quand neige le vrai jo choc
thermique vraiment
j'ai donc mis toute mon énergie à
oublier ses passes et ses
origines indiennes ces seize mois dans
le dos en inde et ses neuf mois dans le
ventre de ma mère
je me suis murée dans le silence
j'ai sombré dans l'anorexie les ts les
fugues et surtout j'avais décidé
qu'aucun de mes rêves de serai à ma
portée
par les dons passés il faire référence
était une tare
il faiblesse
je ne voulais pas être identifié vous
définit comme la fille adoptée
j'avais tellement entendu ces petites
phrases qui me dégoûtait est un petit
chat bien nos chances d'être ici
tes parents sont merveilleux quand même
j'ai bien mieux ici que là-bas un
chanceux d'être ici plutôt qu'en inde et
tu dois tellement à tes parents
et moi là dedans
comment je pouvais exister derrière ses
parents si extraordinaire qui m'avait
permis de sortir d'un destin peu
glorieux
je tiens à préciser que jamais mes
parents non cet état d'esprit
jamais ils l'ont fait en sorte que je
leur soir redevable
mais la société l'a fait pour eux et moi
j'ai accepté de prendre ces rolls
tout ces phrases vous forger des
croyances
tulle est forte la meilleure parfaite
tu as déjà bien marchand d'art a été a
été accueilli et aimé alors ne commence
pas te plaindre à t'écouter tu ne dois
pas montrer que tu va mal tu dois être
reconnaissante et ne prouve et provoquer
de soucis à aucun de tes proches tu dois
prouver que tu mérite d'exister
et d'être là
je devais me faire une place
montrer que je n'étais pas une
imposteure
que je n'avais voler la place de
personne sur cette terre
je ne suis pas seul à avoir vécu et
ressenti c'est vide cette détresse cette
peur ou cette difficulté à être
tellement moi même nous sommes des
milliers
wade millions
pourquoi s'infliger autant de
souffrances
personne n'a demandé à renaître
personne n'a pu maîtriser son arrivée
dans ce monde là pu choisir la famille
de ses rêves ou le pays de ses rêves
est ce qu'on a on ne se doit pas tous de
se créer à la vie que l'on veut de la
faire sienne un autre hommage et de
faire les choix que l'on veut
alors ne laissez jamais personne vous
jugez géré qui vous êtes ce que vous
avez le droit de faire ou dicter vos
rêves il vous appartiennent et personne
n'a le droit de vous les retirer
s'il ya une chose à retenir c'est celle
là chaque épreuve chaque joie chaque
douleur chaque réussite vous amène être
la meilleure version de vous même
alors si chacun de vous ce soir vous
prenez la décision d'enfin oser de
nouvelles d'expérience pour aller
titiller vos rêves les plus fous
et enfin être pleinement acteur de votre
vie
voilà le plus beau cadeau que vous
puissiez vous faire et vous n'êtes pas
là ce soir par hasard
en tout cas moi je suis persuadé que
rien n'est pas un hasard et que tout a
un sens
dès mon plus jeune âge j'en ai eu la
preuve
je vous ai dit il ya quelques minutes
que j'avais toujours le sourire et que
tout le monde disait de moi que j'étais
un rayon de soleil
mon prénom indien et ce matin je vais
dire sourire
mon prénom français hélène qui veut dire
soleil en grec je vous laisse méditer
sur cela
la troisième étape fut de créer ma
propre famille
transmettre mes origines donner de
l'amour il n'y avait rien du beau brun
de plus grand mais rien de plus
déstabilisant questionnant et flippant
pour une personne qui a été abandonné à
la naissance
alors je me devais pour elle de savoir
qui j'étais de partir sur ce chemin pour
guérir définitivement cette blessure de
l'abandon qui te marque au fer rouge
mes filles alors fou rire
leur amour leur joie de vivre ont été
une des clés pour me permettre de
m'accepter et de mai mais
je me suis enfin donné le droit
d'exister
non pour moi même et j'ai arrêté de
culpabiliser de vivre
la quatrième et dernière étape qu'il me
reste à effectuer
j'ai envie de la partager avec vous de
la vivre avec vous ce soir sa carte
grâce à vous ce soir
je réalise un de mes rêves
alors merci à vous d'y contribuer
grandement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
oh
non
tu m'as donné quelque chose n'est plus
fort mais la vie
la mort de
ces neuf voix dans ton ventre
mme o'donnell envie
et même la rage d'exister de me battre
edv enthousiasmé pour las
quelle chance
j'ai eue d'avoir passé neuf mois
merci
le monde soit deux mois
de mémé
et de transmettre
cet arrachement à thouars après neuf
mois de cohabitation
je les transforme en un cadeau tellement
précieux
[Musique]
j'ai eu de la chance et épaulettes
d'habitants toi
et ces instants de vie resteront
indélébile dans l'est moins dans cette
partie de mon corps
maugard
j'ai pas fait tellement d'heures à te
chercher
à pleurer ton absence
arrivé à voir une photo de toi
et à espérer qu'on serait sans compter
sur moi
dans l'âme et dans mon aide
je suis en paix
[Musique]
j'ai besoin que tu saches que j'étais
pardon
et je pense maman
que le pardon il ya plus grande forme et
herman
bon j'espère le beau redonner de
l'espoir les ornements
ablain d'enfants adoptés de bars et de
marc soleil
il est possible d'être
le chemin du pardon
et douloureuse
sommet d'embûches
mais loi tombe
je me considère comme chanceuse
j'ai en moi pour toujours
non
et grâce à toi
j'ai rencontré les personnes les plus
aisées vente
plus belle
brian
et les plus courageux je voulais vous
papa maman
je vous ai le plus crucial
je peux histoire on a ce mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]